ok next one was picture of Israelis
plates you form let's try something
different okay this is interesting black
and capture now left three and try to
get some play here on the forum uh huh
interesting usually the Queen retreats
all the way back to the one
try to get some active peace play going
with Bishop c5
because what the White has some has
gained the bishop pair but like at least
has got them some active pieces and I
have chances to get play on on d4 put
some peace there okay let's finish
development ra3 okay i want to go for d5
now what is prepare the smooth
and I could play D Phi Phi think adopt
that here could could take on on d5
looks like really a lot of development
let's try this not waste too much time
if he takes d5 a couple of times I've
worked the eight and the end then maybe
whoop Dee one white still hasn't got his
Queen side piece is developed okay now i
see that i could also play rook e8 yeah
this is maybe even more interesting
if it tries to cover the f1 square again
I'm probably have 95 as well idea is
simply to to give the check here and the
rook on the first rank will make it very
hard for him to get the rest developed
okay this is some bit surprising i can
take be to now or f2 with check for take
me to what what does he do that f2 is
all signing a one as well okay Queen f2
or is there some better better move so I
just go cool at him okay now there are
many interesting moves look fo a rookie
to does he have anything
we should d force also interesting when
my my play Queen f1 or silly similar
move
looks completely learning but I don't
see it play h6 first my own yes'm I
thought awful I thought I need to
retreat the bishop
ok some it's an extra porn but I lost a
lot of time while trying to find a
direct win which was them I'm pretty
sure but didn't see it
just try to activate the pieces even
more rocky to maybe to come or ideas of
the secondly exchange perhaps a five
okay let's let's play quickly now I'm
already somewhat behind on time
don't think the exchange exchange
sacrifice would be working though
unfortunately
time warning well maybe it is ok now
Knight f3 I thought
yeah this wins the Queen at least check
check
at the moment the two pieces he's got
them don't coordinate very well so maybe
have some possibility to to win more
material even okay let's get the ape on
going
it's not easy for him to move because of
all the checks yeah yeah what this
wasn't wasn't tenable position i think
but I'm as I'm so curious about about
this year let's do a quick computer
check yeah yeah just Bishop takes that
rookie one no idea Queen you have to
just look powerful yeah computer
actually wants to play h6 as well yeah I
pretty much agrees with the moves I
played know maybe there wasn't them I
could complete direct win of course I
should should take with the bishop now
Blair rookie one would be simple yeah
well at least a relatively clean win